well joe biden's team confirming at
least three people associated with the
campaign have tested positive for
coronavirus
the news forcing senator kamala harris
to cancel
travel at a crucial time it's also
highlighting a stark difference in media
coverage compared to what we saw
when hope hicks was first diagnosed with
the virus the headline of the article in
salon.com saying quote
the audacity of hope hicks and her boss
getting coveted 19. jokanchi is a media
reporter for the hill he joins us now
joe it's
always good to see you i was looking at
the coverage and kind of doing some
history and
and going over what happened a couple of
weeks ago when the white house outbreak
happened versus now
and i find it fascinating and i want to
put this on the screen this is alternet
which is a left-wing
publication and their headline reads the
following here here are four ways
biden's team's response to positive cova
test shows the breadth
of trump world's incompetence it's
amazing that only
when you have an outbreak of covet in
the biden campaign
can some blame the trump white house
well you always have to bring trump into
the conversation right he blots out the
sun even though this is a story
about joe biden's campaign in kamala
harris with less than three weeks
until election day being taken off the
trail then again i don't know if
anybody's going to really notice
the senator being taken off the trail
because i've never seen
a more invisible candidate ever run for
office of the stature in terms of the
vice presidency and the presidency since
i guess joe biden because think about
this trace
she was chosen as joe biden's running
mate more than two months ago
she has yet to do one press conference
she has yet to do one gaggle with
reporters
she has yet to do one remotely tough
interview
in all this time so yeah kamala harris
will be taken off the trail but then
again will anybody really notice
are you are you curious at all about the
lack of scrutiny
that the positive tests in the biden
campaign and people associated with
kamala harris
is getting in the media right now joe i
mean it seems to me
you read the articles they certainly
state that she you know she has her
communications director and someone who
was on the plane and somebody else
but there doesn't seem to be a lot of
deep dive and delving into this
the way you would think one would want
to kind of
contact trace this in the media
yeah and not just the deep dives trace
but the condescension
the snark that we see related always
wanted something about the trump
campaign in terms of
blaming people for getting coven 19
automatically assuming that it was
reckless behavior
in terms of how they contracted it that
means that's a pretty dicey thing to do
politically because that means you're
blaming
the millions and millions of people who
tested positive for this virus and maybe
they did everything right and maybe
there isn't everything that we know at
this point
in terms of how you can get it so yeah
if i were teaching a zoom class at this
point
i would call it selective outrage 101
because when it happened with trump
that was very different from what we're
hearing or in this case not hearing
about when it comes to the biden
campaign
and kamala harris yeah i want to move on
if i can joe to this whole
the steve scully controversy you know
he's been suspended
he of course the c-span he was going to
moderate the second debate which was
cancelled
uh he said that his twitter account got
hacked last week and he did not send
that tweet
to anthony scaramucci and now he's
saying okay i did send it i apologize
chris wallace last week when this whole
thing broke we had him on a few minutes
ago and i'm going to play a sound bite
for him
when the whole thing broke he was saying
look he got hacked it looked like you
know
it looked like he was not guilty of this
and and today chris said this
watch unfortunately as we've all learned
in our
professional lives and sometimes in our
personal lives
people do things you don't expect them
to do they turn out you know to have
told you something that turns out to
have been a lie
i i it's very sad uh
and he's going to pay a price for it and
i think ultimately the commission
pays a price for it because they chose
him as a moderator
what's the price in your estimation joe
for this
media bias
i think it's a permanently damaged
reputation unfortunately in this case
trace and i understand where chris
wallace is coming from
chris wallace has been in the news
business for more than 50 years steve
scully was at c-span for more than 30
years he gave
somebody he's known for a while and
respected the benefit of the doubt if
you remember also i was on with you
last week at this time right after chris
wallace was on and i was skeptical
because i
found two things very odd scully never
put out a statement saying that i was
hacked so his silence was telling
and then the fact that if you hack a
presidential debate moderators account
is your first order of business to
really send the scaramucci tweet and
that's your only order of business
and then it goes away so look the debate
commission here
i think canceled that debate the second
one that was supposed to happen last
night
i don't think it was so much about the
president having kovitz and the risk
factors i think
it was the fact that if steve scully
moderated that debate and they knew that
there was something fishy about that
boy could you imagine if that debate all
went off last night after this news
broke about him lying
about it by the way there's an fbi
investigation about this too so it's not
so much the so-called crime
it's the cover-up that's the problem
here for steve scully and i gotta put
this on the screen this is anthony
scaramucci the response
speaking of canceling here he said this
he was the one of course who got the
tweet
he says i get that he got suspended
meaning steve scully for the lie
but the punishing cancel culture is over
the top is it over the top joe
no it is not because again if you have
the fbi and twitter
investigating this after he lied that
should have been enough all he had to do
was say i was joking around i i sent
something to scaramucci
nothing to see here it would have
probably gone away instead by covering
it up
this is what's led to him probably not
working at c-span for a long time
because again once you look at steve
scully this is the first thing you're
going to think of and that's a shame
that's a shame
joe contra good to see you thank you sir